The first thing we need to do in order to start simplifying this expression is
to identify which terms are like terms. Negative 5x squared is the only term in
this expression that has an x to the 2nd power in it. So, it is not like terms
of anything else here. However, we have 6x and negative x. At first sight, these
might both seem related to the x squared term. But remember, the power of the
term matters. Both of these terms have x to the firsts. Remember, there are
little invisible ones written when you just have a variable on its own. x is
just equal to x to the 1st. Anyway, these two terms are like terms. So, I'm
going to start to rewrite this expression with the like terms next to one
another. Remember that the sign of the term, it belongs to the term itself, and
moves along with it when we rearrange the order. Then the two terms that we
haven't written yet are 14 and negative 3. These are just numbers, so they are
definitely like terms, and we'll keep them next to one another. Now, that we've
identified which terms are like terms, it's time to combine those like terms.
So, negative 5x squared stays by itself, since we can't combine it with anything
else. For the x to the 1st terms, we end up with a new coefficient of 6 minus 1
or 5, so, plus 5 times the variable, which is x. And then all we have left to
deal with are the numbers, 14 minus 3 is 11 so we add 11 to the end. Once we've
written down our final expression, we can check and make sure that none of the
terms in it are like terms of one another. That is, we only have one term of
each type in the final expression. This is an x squared term, this is an x to
the 1st term, and this is a constant term. So, there's nothing more that we can
combine. That means that we've reached the final stage of our simplification.
Awesome.